[Musique]
bien sûr que je connais Transformers et
d'ailleurs et ça a été dans recréé deux
et puis Canal+ et qui ne connaît pas
voyons enfin
[Musique]
c'est quelque chose qui se refuse pas
quand j'étais appelé j'étais surprise
flatté et totalement tétanisé c'est
quand même assez extraordinaire c'était
une chance
il fallait dire j'ai dit oui parce que
ça m'a ça m'a plu et ça m'a ça m'a ému
et si bon c'est une aventure à tenter on
va voir
le doublage alors d'abord c'est pas ma
spécialité j'avais déjà fait une fois
mais c'était une sorcière et c'était un
rôle drôle là c'est quand même c'était
très très pointu grâce à son pouvoir
unique on possède son âme
et à l'instar de des raisons l'équipe de
parenthoust m'a reçu magnifiquement bien
ils m'ont tous pris sous leurre
Pauline Hillary Rodolphe et là j'étais
dans un cocon j'étais protégée j'étais
sous les ailes derrière les autres
[Musique]
est une des maximals c'est une nouvelle
espèce dans les Transformers mon nom est
et Resort je suis une maximale une
guerrière de votre passé comme de votre
futur qui protège un petit peu tout le
monde et
Resort c'est un faucon qui
qui est très sage
Optimus nous devons nous faire confiance
pour protéger ce monde que nous
partageons en plus grâce à ces facultés
de voler elle surveille tout donc nous
avons fuit notre planète à la veille de
sa destruction nous sommes réfugiés et
cachés sur la terre c'est très important
mais c'est son côté
sage et protecteur exactement comme
l'équipe qui m'a reçu ici
les années 90 pour moi hey c'est des les
Bercy et surtout mon grand voyage en
Chine
[Musique]
c'était absolument
époustouflant de t'avoir avec nous dans
l'équipe des Transformers
parce que sur Resort sur le personnage
desors Dorothée a apporté
la sagesse la douceur et Dorothée à la
portée quelque chose d'extrêmement fort
en jeu en intensité des terrorcons ce
sont les serviteurs d'un dieu maléfique
qui se nourrit de planète entière pour
se maintenir en vie il est si grand que
ça ce mec il mange des planètes donc
ouais carrément plus grand qu'une
planète
attention 7 juin date à retenir sont des
grands écrans ne manquer sous aucun
prétexte Transformers
rise of the beast ok je compte sur vous
OK
[Musique]
je connais ces Transformers et
évidemment parce que je suis une fan de
SyFy et j'ai vu le premier par Michael
Bay puis les autres et
je vais dire à quel point je suis fan de
Transformers j'ai pris l'avion depuis la
réunion pour venir faire le test
pour pour le casting quoi pour pour la
voix tellement je voulais le faire quoi
je suis complètement hétéro de ça
deuxième classe Noah jazz armée
américaine nombreuses citations un génie
de l'électronique c'est un soldat
pour décrire le personnage d'Arcy c'est
d'abord c'est un soldat c'est c'est
quelqu'un de fiable c'est une gentille
elle est carrée
elle est toujours là pour les pour les
pour ses amis les Transformers pour les
aider c'est elle se transforme en moto
j'adore et c'est une badass quoi
si je me suis attaché à aux personnages
pendant le doublage d'abord ça a été
super court donc j'ai je me suis plus
amusé par ici
que j'ai pas vraiment le temps de
m'attacher à elle mais ça m'a donné
vraiment envie de faire de la moto
c'est histoire d'un jeune garçon qui
s'appelle Noah qui essaie de tant bien
que mal de s'occuper de sa famille de
son petit frère sa mère et
dans ses aventures il se trouve qu'il
rencontre mirage t'approches pas je
croyais qu'on était pas et ils
deviennent amis et mirage le conduit à
européen des Autobots enfin des
Transformers et donc il rencontre tout
le monde et il se ligue avec Optimus et
les autres pour pour combattre et avec
les maximums aussi qui sont des animaux
enfin ça je veux pas trop balancer pour
combattre les
scepticots voilà ce film il faut
vraiment le voir sur un grand écran ne
serait-ce que pour pouvoir le travail
qui a été fait c'est incroyable
c'est la première fois que je fais du
doublage j'ai adoré j'ai fait j'ai fait
une dizaine de films pareil une dizaine
de séries j'ai aussi fait un peu de
j'avais fait une chanson pour le Bossu
de Notre-Dame que j'avais chanté en
français qui était chanté par l'est
jamais de doublage comme ça et
franchement je suis piqué ça y est j'ai
envie d'en faire plein enfin si on me
permet si Arcis survit à ce film j'ai
peut-être que je serai là encore une
fois
quand on est fan des Transformers on est
obligé d'être fan et Optimus Prime quoi
c'est le chef
il y en a tellement des souvenirs de
cette décennie
déjà en tant que chanteuse parce que
j'ai les disques d'or les disques de
platines la scène les films j'ai eu la
chance de dire dans un canard que je
rêvais de tourner avec Lelouch et j'ai
eu la chance de tourner avec Lelouch
donc c'était assez exceptionnel quoi
d'autre les Victoires de la Musique la
nomination c'était c'était la c'était la
folie quoi
la bande-son est extraordinaire parce
que je retrouve plein de morceaux que
que j'écoutais en préparant avant de
sortir ou des morceaux sur lesquels je
faisais mon sport
et c'est vraiment il y a du bon son ce
film
[Musique]
ça a été d'abord un vrai bonheur et un
très grand honneur de travail avec
Ophélie elle a été hyper professionnelle
et elle incarne complètement assis parce
que c'est un personnage qui est
énergique c'est une vraie badass
qui est positive qui a une très très
belle énergie et Ophélie elle a apporté
tout ça avec
avec son trac au démarrage et puis
terminant avec une une aisance et une
voilà une joie d'être avec nous
cette fois c'est très dur à dire
elle m'a énormément aidé
le truc je reproduisais vraiment c'est
vraiment tort non non
c'est pas un exercice simple quand voilà
quoi
c'est pas un exercice simple il faut
savoir voilà placer son énergie placer
sa voix et Ophélie elle s'est au jeu
vraiment avec beaucoup beaucoup de
d'enthousiasme et de facilité voilà
[Musique]
alors rendez-vous le 7 juin au cinéma
pour voir Transformers rise of the beast
[Musique]